Je voulais juste remercier tout le monde d'être
venu ce soir grâce à un travail acharné et
beaucoup d'amour mes parents ont créé
quelque chose de très rare un bon mariage quand
reviendrez-vous dépend du tropique je
dis bonjour Marjorie Duvall a déménagé ici après
le divorce il y a cinq ans mademoiselle Duvall
le corps a été découvert tôt ce matin la
maladie du crime suggère que c'était l'
œuvre d'un tueur en série notoire qui
se dit sortir ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique
]  amant un homme froid
qu'est-ce que l'homme fait pour que tu prennes deux amis
[Musique]
tu n'avais qu'à regarder en toi yahzee
et tu sais ce qu'ils disent deux peuvent garder
le secret si l'un d'eux est mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]